[Music]
good stuff check it out I could see
here's the thing kids don't care how
famous their parents are that is NBA
superstar Steph Curry and his now five
year old daughter Riley in an ESPN
commercial clearly stuff and his wife
Aisha know who is the boss in their
house she is such a star that's let me
know I could watch her all day long and
Wendy Jill Turner drop by two Curry's
Bay Area home she learned just where a
Miss Riley got her warrior personality
from watch me Naenae I think when you
see Riley on the podium I said that's
exactly how I would have acted back when
I was a kid okay so dad maybe the NBA is
201 Million Dollar Man and mom Aisha has
her very own Food Network cooking show
but let's all admit it Riley is the real
star of the curry family so should the
five-year-old get her own reality TV
show there's something we've talked
about yeah we won't go down that road
you know I don't think he'll ever see
what's definitely as a dad Eve never is
too busy for his children we saw the
carpool karaoke the frozen cards did you
score major dad points I did Riley was
super impressed that I knew most of them
want a song word
[Applause]
but not only is staff a great dad he's
also all about his woman these two have
been in love since they were teens
married six years and ladies this MVP
even helps out in the kitchen this is my
dish because it's the only dishes okay
yes
yeah which expect of course the curries
are cooking with Ayesha's brand-new
kitchenware collection I created this
honestly for myself I wanted stuff that
I could leave that on the counter and I
felt like it was beautiful Jager bribed
me and baby sister two-year-old Ryan
also get in on the cooking action so the
big question could we see more cute
babies in the future mom we've been
begging me for like a year now
[Music]
you